Speaker 1: We have another one of these situations
where an anti vaccine pro Trump individual,
in this case a radio host, has been hospitalized
with covid.
This is Phil Valentine.
He's really sick.
I hope he doesn't die.
He is really, really sick.
And we will get to that in a moment.
Now, these stories are really starting to
almost, in a sense, get old.
Two weeks ago, I told you about the anti vaccine
nurse who died in her 30s.
Young anti vaccine nurse died of covid last
week.
I told you about the anti vaccine pro Trump,
Cape Cod elected official.
I believe her name was Linda Zwirner.
Concern something like that.
She died.
And then now we have a right wing radio host.
Slate reporting conservative radio host skeptical
of vaccines, hospitalized with covid, quote,
he's regretful.
This is Phil Valentine, a conservative radio
host in Tennessee who was openly skeptical
about covid vaccines, has been hospitalized
and is now in critical care with the disease.
Phil Valentine, who hosts a show on Nashville's
WWT and was diagnosed with the coronavirus
and is now, quote, in very serious condition
as he battles pneumonia, his family said in
a statement posted to the radio stations Twitter
account.
Although he needs help breathing, Vallentine
is not on a ventilator as of a few days ago.
The latest report is he is not getting better
while making it clear that the experience
has changed his stance on vaccination, a statement
was posted by Supertax WTN.
This is reportedly from his family.
Phil contracted the covert virus a little
over a week ago and has since been hospitalized
and is in very serious condition, suffering
from covid pneumonia and the attendant side
effects.
He is in the hospital in the critical care
unit, breathing with assistance, but is not
on a ventilator.
We'd ask that everyone refrain from contacting
him while he's in the hospital.
Phil would like for his listeners to know
that while he has never been an anti Voxer,
he regrets not being more vehemently or vehemently
pro vaccine and looks forward to being able
to more vigorously advocate that position
as soon as he's back on the air, which we
hope will be soon.
Phil and his family would like for you all
to know that he loves you all and appreciates
your concern, thoughts and prayers more than
you will ever know.
Please continue to pray for his recovery and
please go get vaccinated.
Of course, the prayers would not be necessary
had he been vaccinated from the beginning.
This is a perfect example of 20/20 hindsight.
Now, I know there are people in the audience
who say, screw this guy.
I hope he recovers and I hope that he spreads
the wisdom of vaccination.
I hope he recovers so we can find out if he's
really learned anything from this.
But I am betting that the rest of his right
wing paradigm on which the anti vaccine stuff
was based is going to remain wholly intact.
Now, one other thing I want to mention.
He said the family statement says he was never
anti vax, but he was not.
As for the vaccine as he should have been,
this is a very common talking point that's
used, which is the covid anti vaccines will
say, I'm not anti vaccine, that I'm I'm fine
with other vaccines and I've received other
vaccines.
That doesn't really mean that much because
the other vaccines are ones that there is
so much acceptance of in society that it really
doesn't actually matter whether this guy is
for or against the MMR, because other than
some little anti VAX clusters that eventually
pop up, we've got very solid immunity against
measles, mumps and rubella.
It's it's really a red herring to say I'm
not anti vaccine, that I'm OK with the other
vaccines.
This is the one that I'm skeptical of.
This is what's present right now.
This is the near and present danger at this
point in time.
Let's I'm hoping for his recovery because
I don't want anybody to die.
That's my view.
And I know some in the audience feel differently.
We just have a disagreement.
What we can't possibly disagree about is that
Monday, August 16th, marks the 16th anniversary
of The David Pakman Show.
Wow.
Can you imagine that?
And we will be doing a one day membership
special in commemoration of that.
Get on my newsletter at David Pakman Dotcom.
And Monday, August 16th, you'll get an email
telling you how to avail yourself of that
amazing membership discount.
I would love it, quite frankly, I mean, I'm
not going to hide it, I would love it if you
grabbed a membership on my website is the
primary funding source for our program.
We are an independent, progressive media show.
We have no money tree in the backyard.
I've got an eggplant back there, quite an
eggplant.
In fact, I posted my eggplant plant to my
Instagram over the weekend, but no money tree
still looking on a low chill variety of that.
But no, in all seriousness, I would love it
if you signed up on my website.
Join Pakman Dotcom.
We do an extra show every day for our paid
subscribers, and it really makes it so that
when YouTube revenue goes up, down or disappears
or Facebook revenue goes up, down or disappears,
the membership revenue keeps us closer to
stable.
And many of you know that.
And you can use the coupon code better.
Twenty one to get a membership at join Pakman
Dotcom